all right let's get into the show me
something draft for week four peter
you're uh you're up first what do you
got
hey listen carson wentz has to show me
something you know the philadelphia
eagles are already going down the yellow
brick road of torture
and they're already really fortunate
that they're not letting fans in their
own stadium because carson wentz would
have gotten booed out of that stadium by
this point
and now he gets an opportunity
against a beat up san francisco defense
to come out and play a game away from
home
and and to me
this is a golden opportunity to begin
the carson wentz rehab show
and that rehab has to has to include
taking what the defense gives you and in
the immortal words of mike florio
stop trying to score 20 points on every
drive
uh that's a good one and i'll tell you
what for me and for all the reasons
we've discussed today and really all
week since tuesday morning lamar jackson
show me what you can do after getting
humbled the way that you did on monday
night football on a short week can you
reestablish yourself as the great player
that you are or will this one linger
with you will you start to force it will
you start to try to do too much to show
everyone that you're the defending mvp
so i want to see lamar jackson in a game
that the ravens should win easily what
can they do peter
show me something nfl players
and show me something nfl coaches
okay take
it very very seriously
that just because you go through the
first 15 days of testing
uh zero positives for 2
460 players
it's not over
no it's not over
it continues and it continues every
single day
show me something don't put yourself in
position to get covered 19
and to derail your team season and
perhaps the nfl season
good one peter and a wise uh message
that everyone needs to take seriously
especially the nfl players if they want
to get the games in all right next one
for me
we talked about this earlier in the show
seattle defense show me something fits
magic is in full effect turn him into
fits tragic if you want to be a
championship caliber team you're not
going to have russell wilson throwing
five touchdown passes every single game
and winning it for you every single game
at some point you got to step up and you
got to play this is your chance go to
miami shut down ryan fitzpatrick and
shut up the people who are saying what
happened to the legion of boom
show me something kyler murray
and the reason that i say that in in a
game that is maybe
the least
uh it will draw the least attention this
weekend arizona carolina
okay look in the first two weeks of the
season we all said oh my god cardinals
succeed in the playoffs they're they're
they mean it they're good they're
impressive well then they have a clunker
at home against an 0-2 detroit team okay
so now
show me something kyler murray show me
that you are not going to be mortally
wounded by a horrible home loss and you
can go on the road in a game that you
should
win and you go on the road
in some difficult circumstances coming
off that loss
show me kyler murray that you can lift
your team to a road win
when times are tough in the nfl
and that's a great one peter because for
me the line of demarcation between a
good team and a bad team is a good team
beats bad teams when it's supposed to
and you can't lay an egg against the
detroit lions and expect to be regarded
as a good team and if you do it twice in
a row against a rebuilding panthers team
then you have to wonder are the
cardinals ready to consistently win and
be in the mix in the nfc west so i like
that one very much all right i'm torn
for my last one between two guys and i
think i've got it figured out i was
gonna go nick foles but how can you say
show me something to a to a super bowl
mvp he's already shown us that he's cape
right so i'm gonna give him the benefit
of the doubt how about the guy who's
still ascending or not baker mayfield
you made the point perfectly earlier in
the show going back to texas his home
state big stage if he stays with the
browns he's only going to play there
once every eight years this is your
chance baker mayfield
to show that you belong on the same
field as dak prescott to show that the
cleveland browns aren't just a jim brown
three yards and a cloud of dust team
that their quarterback can get it done
this is his chance either he does or he
doesn't and maybe that's why he was
talking earlier this week about the
possibility of a shootout because maybe
deep down peter he wants one because he
wants to prove to all of us that he
belongs
over time mike we each get an extra one
in the extra period i'll say show me
something cam newton because really i
think
everybody who loves the new england
patriots and a lot of people who hate
the patriots look at cam newton as my
god what is the first month of the nfl
season proven that he's really really
better than we thought he was going to
be now he's got to be better against the
best team in football on the road
that is a show me game for cam newton
and i want to see it
yeah that's a great point and i'm going
to stay in that same general baker
mayfield territory there's been a lot of
comparisons between mayfield and gardner
minshew minshew did not look good last
thursday night he was constantly
harassed by that miami pass rush in
cincinnati that's not going to be the
case going against the new flavor of the
month joe burrow if the jaguars aren't
going to be in consideration for trevor
lawrence this is the kind of game they
have to win and they're underdogs that's
the ultimate slap in the face so i like
that gardner minshew moxie i like his
attitude i like his style
he's got to win though and if he doesn't
win this one we start looking at the
jaguars the way we thought peter we were
going to be looking at the jaguars all
season long notwithstanding that upset
of the colts to start the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports